no no bummer is is this shirt is
actually it's coming across very black
on here but it's actually dark blue it's
that's that it's more accurate than it
looks
uncharted for a thief's end so uncharted
4 is the newest chapter in the Uncharted
series to be honest with you guys I was
a little I don't want to say salty about
this game but I mean Amy Hennig the
creative director of Uncharted 1 2 & 3
I'm a big fan of hers she also did the
Soul Reaver series she was let go or
fired from Naughty Dog know like hey
here's Uncharted for granted it's a
creative team behind the Last of Us good
creative team I thought all right
without Amy Hennig is gonna lose a lot
of the Nathan Drake fun Nathan Drake's
gonna be like Joel or something I had
some fears and then the title of
Uncharted 4 comes on Uncharted 1 2 & 3
it always had the Nathan Drake theme it
was a cool theme you know you're like
it's adventure we're here for adventure
we're gonna have some adventure just
didn't have that has a skeleton in a
cage just swinging so I was like uh-huh
that's what I'm telling you the fun's
gonna be lost then I played the game
found out I was dead wrong because this
game is pretty [ __ ] amazing
so in uncharted 4 Nathan Drake has been
out of the game since uncharted 3 it's a
few years later he's married to Elena
and someone from his past Moana keep it
vague because I didn't watch any
trailers for this game before I played I
just went in fresh I'm glad I did so I'm
gonna keep some information from you if
I can so someone from his past comes
back into his life someone from his
childhood he's like hey remember that
treasure we wanted to find back in the
day when we were kids alright so I found
out where it is we got to find it and
please help me because my life is in
danger that's the one thing that's gonna
drag Nathan Drake back into the game is
to save this guy's life so he's like
alright alright let's do it and when I
first met this guy I was like okay this
guy's gonna be like Dom from Entourage
it's like hey we knew this guy back in
the day and you're like wow this is kind
of intrusive hey I have my crew don't
mess with a good thing who's this guy
but they do him and his friendship with
Nathan Drake so well plus he's voiced by
Troy Baker's of Troy Baker and nolan
north going back and forth actually like
sam it's the dudes name he kicks ass and
he knows a lot about this archaeology
arguably more than nathan drake couple
times drake he'll say something and Sam
will correct him like no no it's that
and Drake's like yeah
right there the guy's worth his salt and
then the two interact more and you're
like alright man you're part of the team
however there is a conflict within what
you thought the story was and I'm
Charlie three showed Nathan drag was his
kid
he was alone and then he met Sully and
they became a team and then you find out
no when he was a kid he knew Sam and
they were paddling around and doing [ __ ]
you're like wait and that's not what I'm
Charlie three told me so again you have
conflict of information that can fit
together as a whole but it's still good
it just kind of changes what you thought
you knew by the end of this game you're
like now we'll take uncharted 4 is word
for it because this game this game but
start out with the graphics first of all
the graphics are insanely great this is
one of those things where you're
watching it you're like I can't believe
we're we're here now everything from the
character models to the scope of the
land it all looks super sick real it's
there's a scene where this lady is
talking there's a window or it's a lie I
think it's a window behind her head and
the light is shining through her hair
you're like that is real human hair and
when you're exploring the layout is so
well crafted that I mean some paths
don't lead anywhere some paths lead to
where you want to go it ultimately heard
you in the right direction but you feel
like there are different branches more
the whole way to skin a cat kind of
thing is like I can go here or I can go
here I can go up this mountain and down
there it does you really feel like you
are exploring this is the greatest
archaeological adventure you can have
while not leaving your couch I don't
think you can we talked about the action
sequences in here holy [ __ ] the action
sequences uncharted is known for its
action sequences like Nathan Drake's
escaping something something's falling
apart the building's falling apart he
grabs onto a Ledge then he slides down
narrowly escapes death in here is like
that but times 10 to collapses and
escapes are so grand in scope I was
playing this I was like this is one of
those games that is so much fun to play
and probably still fun to watch it's not
like Final Fantasy 6 where you're like
hey this is a great game to play oh
you're asleep ok
I get it it's you're watching or not
it's not the same river that's seen in
uncharted 2 where that truck was coming
down the alley and you had to shoot back
at it and you just narrowly escaped
death something like that happens in
this game times is about a billion it's
awesome it's one of those things where I
was like I need to see that in a movie
in fact if I do see that in the movie
and I should it will blatantly be
ripping uncharted 4 off and I'll address
how about you ripped uncharted 4 off
that said you should because I wanted to
see that on the big string because that
is
as for the gameplay it's a lot of what
you already know uncharted to be you
know you duck behind objects you shoot
sometimes the hit detection sucks I say
so let's be honest and every Uncharted
game this one included so many times
it's like I shot you in the head
come on and even if I didn't how many
shots to the throat can you take dude
and the timing oh my god the computer
just knows the timing that those moments
where you're just like all right you got
your scope and you're like oh oh it's
like did you just know do you duck on
the premise that when I pull the trigger
that's actually controlling the bots
character to duck shenanigans I tell the
Uncharted shenanigans one thing that's
missing that I really missed was the
ability to throw grenades back at guys
like in the past and try to get I think
it started in - but definitely three had
it where someone lob a grenade at you
and you can just grab the grenade and
throw it back kind of a logical move to
do if a grenade lands at your feet has a
few seconds before it explodes ready yes
it made grenades a lot less dangerous
when uncharted incorporated that so now
that uncharted 4 is taken that dynamic
away its grenades are back to being
super dangerous so I can't fault him for
cuz I'm Charlie 3 I just did not sweat
grenades at all but there is a new
mechanic that uncharted 4 incorporates
that the Uncharted series has never
really fully embraced and that is
stealth
they have line-of-sight kind of like
Metal Gear Solid they'll see you like
huh let's go check that up right when I
saw it I was like oh my gosh Metal Gear
Solid I was born of this I got super
excited this one area I slaughtered
everybody neck breaking slamming their
heads on the ground
hiding in the flowers and bushes and
jumping up and cracking necks when I
cleared out this entire area Stan was
like oh that got hairy like yeah someone
will have heard that we got to go I was
like oh ask you the game thinks I would
have totally blown it and had to shoot
guns he underestimated the MGS skills
that have honed me throughout time so I
was really glad they incorporated a
Metal Gear Solid esque stealth mechanic
and a new little tool you get is it
grappling there you have this grappling
hook that Yemi grapple on to things and
you climb up or you can swing around it
goes with the action sequences sometimes
sometimes Nathan Drake will swing around
right into a window and you're back into
the mix Frazee insane excitement but the
grappling hook does give you pause you
know like there are a few scenarios
where it's like ugh Nathan Drake's up on
a Ledge look I can't reach you we got to
find something I'm like you have a rope
you actually have a rub that guy can
climb up right now
and um it wouldn't be puzzles because
all the puzzles in the Uncharted games
are what make Uncharted fun you see
these puzzles you're like alright I got
to get all supergene you see right now
is not super really super genius stuff
but it's fun and it really makes you
feel like you're in an Indiana Jones
esque adventure in modern time but in
every game like this it's like the end
boss mechanic is always different in
every other mechanic you die a few times
you don't even feel bad about it he
grinds the momentum of the game to a
halt which is a bummer but you're like
it's a learning curve I haven't used
this mechanic at all in this game until
just now
like at the end of Metal Gear Solid 2
where it's like I'm fighting with swords
now you're like fighting with what I
haven't all right let's kick my ass a
few times because that's just how it's
going to go down
guys in the end uncharted 4 took
everything I loved about I'm trying to
do because I personally liked uncharted
2 more than three because three felt
like a little broken up like the first
half was totally different than the
second half you had a different crew
here in a different route here uncharted
2 had the same crew and twists and turns
throughout then you reach the annual
like that was a whole cohesive thing
super exciting that this is like
uncharted 2 next level [ __ ] it has great
character that kept the character of
Nathan Drake Nathan Drake they upped the
stakes they up the ante and it really
feels like a proper send-off for Nathan
Drake and his crew because this is the
last Uncharted game and by the end of
the game you're playing it you're like
this feels like a show that I've been
watching for about a decade and this is
the last episode of the last season this
is the series finale you put it down and
it's a bittersweet kind of sad feeling
you're fulfilled in a weird way and even
in the end credits to give a special
thanks to Amy Hennig for everything she
has done in the Uncharted series they
didn't have to do that but they did I
thought that was really nice and so as
an Amy Hennig fan good on you guys good
on you Naughty Dog
ain't so naughty I'll say uncharted for
visually gameplay character wise scope
setting I mean you don't you look around
when you're on these cliffs you're like
I'm on a vacation I'm in a different
place and when you can have that and
you're searching for a super pirate
treasure in the mix of all of it this is
uncharted how Uncharted to me is
completely fulfilling on every level and
uncharted 4 is awesome tacular
how's the multiplayer I'm going to be
honest with you guys I haven't even
touched the multiplayer because I'm
charted for it isn't about the
multiplayer it's about the character
campaign of a guy and his crew that's
why I play Uncharted the multiplayer is
gonna be an afterthought to kind of
incorporate multiplayer because
multiplayer is huge among gaming right
now so if the game sells me on the
single-player sure I'll dabble in the
multiplayer now but I didn't want to bog
down my review with multiplayer stuff
like if it was a halo over doom or some
[ __ ] yeah let's talk about multiplayer
but it's not it's uncharted you're on a
single-player adventure have fun with it
right guys so uncharted for a thief's
end have you played it what did you
think about it or what's your favorite
Uncharted game of all time whatever it
is whatever you think comment below let
me know and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more